for decades American taxpayers have been
wrongfully forced to subsidize the
abortion industry through title 10
federal funding so today we have kept
another promise my administration has
proposed a new rule to prohibit title 10
funding from going to any clinic that
performs abortions Democrats in the
Senate are doing everything within their
power to block it on this issue like so
many other issues the Democratic Party
is far outside the American mainstream
that was President Trump delivering the
keynote address tonight at the susan b
anthony lists annual campaign for life
gala part of the president strategy is
to rally the base as we head into the
midterm elections and his focus on
pro-life initiatives they're here to
discuss that it's so much more it's my
friend one of the presidents top
advisors Kellyanne Conway who herself
tonight received the big award from the
susan b anthony list kelly ann it's
great to have me on thank you Laura
by the way the president praised you at
we were watching you know in the back
and this was a fun moment let's watch
she is some fighter she'll do the shows
that nobody else dares go near she Otis
I'll say do this one or that one no
problem sir we're watching all of us and
he's the most I think pro-life president
we've ever had clearly and defending
life the most innocent among us who have
no lobbyists and no fat cats behind them
and it's not his crowd of the Manhattan
crowd but I I'm sorry but I was so moved
by that blur there's no question tonight
in my remarks I took out the letter from
September 2016 that candidate Trump
signed and Margene and felzer Susan
manthang lists one of him to sign his
letter to activate the grassroots sake
hey we need some promises some
commitments from the Republican nominee
so he looked at the letter talked about
partial-birth abortion making the Hyde
Amendment permanent signing the pain
capable unborn
into law if it reached his desk
certainly moving as he just did tonight
the funding from clinics that provide
abortions to those that provide true
women's health services Laura like
mammograms and and screenings and other
services so you looked and he said
that's all fine but where's all that
stuff about Hillary Clinton and he added
stuff about Hillary Clinton you I'm
gonna give you a copy the letter and he
signed it and it went on and on about
how extreme she is that she would take
the baby out of his mother's womb and
elevate the debate moment and then he
followed it up on October 19th and gave
the most impassioned defense of never
ever heard for a presidential debate
podium and let's remind everybody this
is a Manhattan male billionaire who for
most of his adult life had said he was
pro-choice the Liberals really mean it
he doesn't really look at this record
look at his record Mexico City policy
and Yale courses on the Supreme Court
first president ever to address this
gala first president ever to address the
Martin for life and and Mike Pence of
course was the first vice president ever
do the same all you have to do is look
at the policies and President Trump will
probably say this is just a good start
the issue of China is big because so
many of us supported the president
because of his tough line on China they
have the China 20 25 25 plan seeking to
dominate every major industry if stolen
our intellectual property the
president's been fantastic on this issue
but this is what Chuck Schumer said
let's watch I am really concerned about
the president's hemming and hawing over
the last few days when it comes to China
you could say that President Xi is
writing the art of the deal not
president Trump unfortunately every time
President Xi at flatters our president
he seems to back off a tough deal you've
got to be tough on China you have to
have your actions match your rhetoric in
my mind the worst thing that could
happen is that the Democrats out
populist this president on the China
issue that would be a gift to them
Kellyanne can you reassure the viewers
tonight that the president is going to
retain his strength and approach to
China that got him elected well the
president addresses today in the Oval
Office with all the cameras rolling as
he was meeting with President moon from
South Korea and the president made clear
from the beginning he thinks that these
imbalanced unfair non reciprocal trade
deals including with China are killing
the America
worker American interest American
industries and he will always fight for
them first the president talks
extensively about the five hundred
billion dollar trade deficit we have the
China at the same time we're happy that
in some of these negotiations in Beijing
and here last week Lara at the White
House that China signals that a move to
buy more AG buy more energy for example
but the president also if he thinks a
deal is not good for Americans he's
happy to walk away from it he's been
doing that his entire career so you're
not you're not concerned that you hear
Marco Rubio Schumer these guys they see
an opening here because Trump dominated
that space in 2016 no one had done it
like he had done it and now they see Oh
sour gum and soybeans more important
than our entire tech sector that's kind
of ripped off as they continue to steal
our IP and they're playing a long ball
here that they are they're not playing
short while they're playing long ball
for total domination they are and
remember we're talking about technology
transfers ambassador light hydro the US
Trade Representative obviously we never
to Beijing talking about the fact that
they're stealing our innovation stealing
our future frankly you know future
innovation mission and light Heiser on
different sides on this is there a real
war going on as I think that people like
to cover palace intrigue instead of
learning the policies because a divided
party they want entrees Donald Trump and
he came out I think one of the issues
that he was able to elevate to the
issues Donald Trump was able to elevate
as a candidate Laura from mired in slow
single digits to putting it out there in
the platform was illegal immigration in
truth he took those way from I mean
little little single business all the
way up there about fairness to him
they're both under herded by fairness
and it's fairness to America um North
Korea meeting shifting moving can you
tell us anything new on that well the
White House put out a statement tonight
asking the press to sign up if they're
going to cover the summit in Singapore
and so we're still pondering over we're
still planning on the July 12th but the
president has made very clear from the
beginning and said it again today that
if it happens that's great if it doesn't
happen that's okay too maybe it won't
happen on June 12 what happened a later
date we're still way ahead I had we
still made tremendous progress there
Laura because of president Trump's
leadership without him
North Korea would not be talking to
South Korea those three American
detainees would not be back he was
hinting that she was part of the perhaps
Charlie said quote I think Argentine is
a world-class poker players what he said
that was his exact quote I'm not blaming
anyone just saying something happened
and and so what we're looking what the
president has said is that we'll
continue to make progress continue to
talk but remember the goal here is not
to have a summit the goal is the
denuclearization of the Korean Peninsula
and that's what the president is looking
at John Bolin I'm gonna be going on the
trip I think he would be hopes over
there they don't want him there but I
hope I hope he does come Killian
congratulations on the award thank you
so much thanks for congratulations for
to the most pro-life president in
American history for keeping his
promises absolutely